i just want to say chris pedophilia i
just wanted to say that
i was trying to find it i was trying to
find a way to slide it in
i i was just babbling on trying to find
a way to slide in it
i couldn't do it you know what i mean
yeah and then jeff ross
got in some me too heat you know the
roast molester chest
now i heard she gave you an ipad did you
think that was a woman's product did you
even know what it was
you know that's the truth i know nothing
about if the television goes
with the blinking at midnight i don't i
don't know the first thing about it
but now i got it on television after
midnight
how about how about how about shut up
did someone does someone lose their
child i'm sorry all right
you know you know they had to create an
imax just for the two movies that he
made
there's two there's two movies
and when was the first time that you
guys if it's okay to talk about it when
was the first time you guys had sexual
intercourse
um probably well two months no that's
not true a month into our relationship
but he had to drive
she didn't even come into my place for a
month did he uber did he drive
i drove to [ __ ] long beach every day
i'm asking
the woman uh he drove down there he did
and
what would he do his filth either he
didn't try to
he didn't try he didn't clean his car he
had piles of like bottles and just
dirty underwear everything oh my god dad
bro it's so gross
from the get-go i knew he was a he was a
pig hi
you know hygiene wise he was a hygiene
risk they called it yeah yeah for sure
hepatitis risk
oh yeah yeah definitely wow
are you asleep away we can talk about
love
what are you god bless there's a new
thing called dress up
thank you i mean we worry about the
homeless but
you're a jew derelict
i've always liked you better than the
other guy thank you
so i better not anyway
god bless you black and white we're
working for a same cause
to find you work anyway we're doing so
great will be god bless you
dressed as a jew and safari anyway uh
i've never met a name anyway
hallelujah get the black chick to back
it up
[Applause]
north macdonald's so stoned he thinks
he's in a roast for bob seeger
i love you norm wow you never come out
knowing you're like the jd
salinger of dick jokes
so you've made so many films in the last
few years have you ever thought of just
slowing down and making just
one good one
jimmy jimmy you're like the pumpkin
spice latte see you're a little too
sweet
but the white people love you it's one
of those weird things
see over under tonight what's gonna
happen norm no i wanted to read
something funny so i'm reading marmaduke
oh my god this is what happens when
you're booking deus off craigslist
and someone said that that he has a
slurpee machine oh crystalline has an
ice cream maker in his house and doesn't
even
eat dairy that's why i'm just there well
that's
that's over abundance and that's rich
people doing rich [ __ ] yeah someone said
he has four couches dude and there's a
man out there and a woman out there
trying to make love on a floor somewhere
while that [ __ ] is sitting there
with four couches
[ __ ] him dude and he ain't a champ bro
he never will be oh [ __ ]
mountain lions running through the
streets is that what you want
no joe you [ __ ] lunatic
somebody gets in my face that might
cause me to get more
lunatic i eat a little bit of protein
you had to beat the [ __ ] out of people
for like three decades before you could
like chill
smoke a little weed put on your little
rascals hat and just [ __ ] chill out
but do you do you do a little exercise
yeah i ride a bike about recumbent bike
twice a day do you watch whatever let me
finish i dave
i know it's your show but i have a
little curtis i'm sorry a little respect
i'm much older than you i understand by
the way that the snow is getting a
little brighter up there
all right thank you you're no
you're the weirdest looking person on
the planet earth thank you thank you
that doesn't
no that doesn't help me at all that's
that's very kind i don't mean that as a
no no no no it's just nobody i can't
describe the fact that i have a full
head of hair that's what's going on well
yeah sure
i just don't have to cover my chin
because i'm proud of it it's not
if you weren't famous and you robbed a
bank yeah and the dude was describing
you to like the
police sketch artist yeah he'd be like
no seriously what did he look like
nobody nobody looks like this
nobody looks like you i can't i can't
believe i'm looking at you all the time
first of all in my defense in my defense
patrice
my number my [ __ ] number on the
trains patrice
my [ __ ] number hasn't changed okay
now if you want to be honest
you disappeared patrice you did this
[ __ ]
he said his number didn't change if i go
find his old number
it will not only go dude
why don't we do the challenge patrice
could call right now and kevin could put
his phone right next to the mic right
now patrice let's do the challenge right
now
define kevin's number because this is
how close me and little cab used to be
sorry mr hart kh
it's kate hart man that's me on the
streets and
and the other legendary thing about
little kev is he has the dick the side
of a baby arm it's really depressing are
you seeing it no but i've heard it
suppresses me
and i don't even need to say the no homo
thing it's just like you know
if if you know girls are like you know
hey hi
how are you the [ __ ] might be
like hey and it's like
hey and he just goes look i got a big
god bless you wonderful kids do you do
so kids you are kids compared to i was
so flattered
when when when robin williams manager
called me and said yeah
yeah managers are [ __ ] spitting up
all over the place
it won't be god bless as you told me
tonight outside
someday it's going to be your whole show
you're gonna you're gonna be the hostess
and you don't need the white jew
and the other penis on the end
oh dude and him and bobby lee this is a
true story you should go down to mexico
uh chris and bobby lisa get out of
mexico to get involved with who knows
what
but they used to go watch mexican
comedians perform and steal their
material and bring it back up to america
how crazy is that instead of saying stop
all the signs say
chill bro sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry um yeah you're not
you're still
you're not giving them you know they
come out they've
parked their cars they've got babies
that they haven't paid why would you
might be mental
but but if i was you i'd be going thank
you
so much these people and giving them you
know what i mean but i'm not doing it it
was shoddy
it was um i mean you know you didn't
write it and that's
but do it like but
do it like it's your do it like you were
clever enough to come up with this joke
yourself
okay dude you got an easy job
this is an easy job are you what are you
talking about what do you mean what am i
talking about jimmy all you do
is read jokes off cue cards that's it
come on my my job's not that easy
jimmy you just read that off of a cute
car that's what you that's fixing stuff
and uh she and i were down there and uh
we were working at the uh
grand casino in outside of memphis
outside how far outside what the hell
are you from the travel agency
i don't remember casino gamble who
should remember nobody what are you what
are you my guardian i'm not going to
tell you where i go
china 40 million jews i got to meet a
truant officer here
you look like a guy that makes really
strong smoothies for drake bro
you look like bro you look like a guy
dude you look like the only guy that
didn't get molested by michael jackson
and grew up
you're sad about it you know what if i
wanted anyone to be president i would
want to be shaq
because shaq can do whatever the hell he
wants shaq can call you in
right now and tell him that he wants to
bomb france they're going to say but why
shaq
they didn't do anything uh i don't know
i don't like the basketball team i think
the basketball team stinks
i want to drop a bomb on him i want to
dunk it
i want to do it
i want to do that shaq ate it
balls he called me with that shack and
you think this shack is going to be good
no i uh we had a wonderful cruise we
went to vietnam i think i told you about
this went to china who takes a cruise to
vietnam oh
no our life is going to be this sitting
here all day long my next guest you
don't do anything for crying out
you sit in the house with your wife
maeve is calling my next guest and she
says you're home more on your home
forget about it
sometimes i feel like a woman dude yeah
well you look like a woman you look like
a woman right now dude you look like
[ __ ] eileen wernose the first female
serial killer
ever killed that's right look at her
haircut google island same
[ __ ] mullet haircut theo dude you
look like eileen
have you even looked at yourself ever
kind of [ __ ]
let's look at her look at that you look
tired